my worry is this if I had enough said
this on bar rescue if there's 60
motorcycles in front of a bar there's a
bunch of people that won't go to that
bar right if there's a bunch of people
dressed in gang colors in front of a bar
there's people who won't go in that bar
today if there's a bunch of people in
front of a bar that look
you're responsible as it relates to
kovat they're customers that won't go in
that bar it's no different let me ask
you a question if I can if you were
gonna bail out two tonight in a
restaurant that was open and there was a
crowd of people in that front of that
restaurant and none of them were
marrying wearing masks would you go in
so it's interesting so I'll tell ya I
have only been to one restaurant since
this all happened it was last week it
was a restaurant right by my house just
a burger joint bar that I go to every
now and again the waitress I was not
wearing a mask there and it was pretty
sporadic so you know I was with one
person the waitress was wearing a mask
and a face guard and you know it's not
that comfortable we you know this you
you need to read people's faces to feel
comfortable it feels sort of weird with
all that I think for me at this point as
a relatively young healthy person if I
went to a nice restaurant let's say in
Beverly Hills or something like that
I would be okay if people were not
wearing stuff I actually would be okay
with that but I don't think I don't
consider myself in the last third that
you just talked about I think I'm
somewhere between the first third and
the second third I think and also you
know here in Los Angeles where we've
been closed for so long I think I'm also
having like a reverse reaction which I
think a lot of people are having which
is like let's just go just go and see
what happens yeah yeah now I worry about
a irresponsibility not on a part of
restaurant owners you know I'm concerned
Dave that a restaurant does everything
right it sanitizes puts their employees
in the proper gear there's all the
procedures in the kitchen all the PPE
attire you know has everything exactly
right but then a bunch of customers come
in without masks create a bad impression
pictures go on social media of this
place pack
then all of the portion of society that
wants to wear masks will never go there
so there's a real challenge for business
today and I think I know the answer but
I'm not quite sure if my answer is right
if you and this is deep dip if you're in
a bar business and you said okay I'm
gonna play country music no rock and
roll people are coming you've made a
decision that's gonna completely segment
your business to country people only so
you're not you're gonna see some boots
you're gonna see some hats you're not
gonna see a lot of Armani suits probably
and it's gonna be a country environment
let's say you chose I don't want to do
that I'm gonna play rock and roll in my
bar okay
no country people there no hip-hop
people there you just segmented your
business to a portion of the population
let's say you say I'm gonna play hip hop
same deal no country no Rock you
segmented yourself into a certain
segment to the population my point is
this
there's the mask wearers and is the non
mask wearers and I think that
restaurants are going to be put in a
position where they're gonna have to
choose just like that music segmentation
either you have to wear a mask in my
restaurant when you're not eating
you have to Ameri west where you're
wearing outside or you don't but I don't
think mixing it is gonna work long term
and that's a really tough choice and
nobody's talking about this in the
industry do it or don't do it what do we
have to do is and it's a segmenting
decision just like music is or price
points are so I'm of the belief that
restaurants need to pick and I'm of the
belief for long term sustainability and
here's what I worry about we are living
in a culture of accountability today
Piko people go out have a bad meal it's
all over Yelp in a matter of minutes
right dirty all so if people get sick in
a restaurant and it's traced back to a
restaurant done
case closed that place will never open
again in New York they're gonna take
liquor licenses away if customers act
irresponsibly so we're at a turning
point as an industry are we going to
allow the behavior of customers to
destroy our investment or are we gonna
regulate that behavior the nightclub
business has been doing this for years
by segmenting by music segmenting by
dress codes and doing segmentation we
survived in a segmented world since I
got in this business all these years ago
I don't believe that we
can succeed as an industry if we don't
choose what side were on and if we
choose to run in an unprotected
environment and choose to not do some of
these processes that can keep people
safe we may pay the ultimate price and
the ultimate price is not only getting
somebody sick or potentially killing
them but destroying your business so I
take an opposite position to you and and
I'm not sure that I would let you in my
restaurant or stand in front of it
without a mask yeah and I totally hear
you I I it's it's it's a personal choice
not only for the the individual consumer
but obviously for the for the owner of
the bar or restaurant do you think what
makes it even more muddled what confuses
it even more is that it's one thing if
you're walking into a clothing store and
you're wearing a mask well you're not
using your mouth you're not using your
face at a restaurant it's like well wait
a minute I can walk in I have to wear
masks let's say when I walk in but we do
know I have to drink through my mouth I
have to eat through my mouth so we so
there's these sort of inconsistencies
where it's like people are just like
more than why am i doing it at all like
it's just it's just the natural
questions that arise well if there's
spacing at the tables and people are
standing in front of the restaurant
without that level of spacing I think
it's reasonable for us to say we'd
appreciate you wearing a mask until
you're seated right seems seems like a
simple definition my worry is this if I
had and I've said this on bar rescue if
there's 60 motorcycles in front of a bar
there's a bunch of people that won't go
to that bar right if there's a bunch of
people dressed in gang colors in front
of a bar there's people who won't go in
that bar today if there's a bunch of
people in front of a bar that look
you're responsible is it relates to
kovat they're customers that won't go in
that bar it's no different so when you
say about how are we going to be
successful there's two issues does that
issue and all of that is driven by this
one premise and bear with me for a
minute David if you you're a burger guy
right you love a good burger yeah oh
yeah oh yeah so let's say that your
favorite burger place in town after this
pandemic you go walk up to it
everybody's packed in there they're not
wearing masks you know they're not even
wearing masks behind the counter the
whole thing just doesn't feel right but
two blocks farther away is your second
favorite burger place
farther but they're clean they're tight
their staff is a mess I mean this place
is together it looks great safe you're
now gonna go to your second favorite
burger place which is farther away than
your first burger place Dave that
changes everything
trust has now ratcheted to the top so
now you're gonna walk farther to go to
your second favorite burger place
because your first favorite burger place
didn't gain your trust well it's
interesting because yeah well it's
interesting because you're talking about
free-market capitalism and and also
talking about rules but ultimately
you're saying it's it's on people to
make the right choices
so if in fact Trust is ratcheting up to
the top of the motivation list of what
businesses I choose to do business with
how do we build trust and this goes back
to your question how do we get
successful now well if we know that we
have thirds then we if we know we have
to build trust for even for you who's
quicker to go out maybe than I am then
how do we build trust
well Trust isn't words Trust is in
advertising campaigns Trust is
transparency right you begin to trust me
as an individual once you get to know me
a little right Trust is built so Trust
is a very difficult emotion to build in
a person so we need to be transparent so
the way we create transparency is by
creating visual standards of what people
see and what they can expect in our
business so for example a few weeks ago
on my social media they have some guys
making lasagna in a kitchen and he posts
a picture of a cook and he's standing in
the stainless steel line and he's laying
over zhonya noodle in the pan and the
post says our famous lasagna will be
ready for curbside pickup at five
o'clock pretty noble effort right guys
not wearing a mask he's wearing a ball
cap from home he's wearing clear she
plastic gloves that if somebody wears in
a salon when they do hair color it's not
even food service rated all the imaging
is wrong so if we don't build trust
nobody's gonna eat that freakin lasagna
so we as an industry have to really
understand how to build trust what are
we what are the marketing communications
of trust when you walk up to the front
door
my business retail restaurant bar what
looks different oh they changed this and
subliminally you're saying well they
changed it for me they're keeping me
safe this is a good thing oh I feel good
about this I like this okay this make
from one little thing all of these
assumptions go through your head so what
has to be different I suggest that every
business needs to change something they
need to change their seating layout they
need to change signage in the front they
need to put a podium out front for
check-in they need to do something that
sends the message of trust in a
transparent way if I can send a message
of trust in this world I can get the
first third the second third and a third
third it trust if that first third limb
slams out social media with untrusting
visuals you're gonna have a hell of a
time getting it to second and third
third so where do you think government
and regulation kind of fit into this
because you know we're hearing all sorts
of arbitrary things or seemingly
arbitrary things every week depending on
where you live you know okay we can be
at 50 percent restaurant capacity but
that's regardless whether you've done
all of these precautions or not done all
of these precautions and I'm sure you
must be hearing from owners of
restaurants and bars who are saying hey
I'll do everything that I possibly can
do I'll put all the investment and we'll
do all the work but if we can only open
at 50% capacity we there's no way we can
succeed regardless of doing everything
or not doing everything well you know I
I don't disagree with you so new revenue
centers need to be found hence delivery
curbside pickup but there are these
third-party delivery apps are destroying
our industry you know they're the only
people who make money you pay them 25 up
to 35% third-party delivery app so so I
begged people on this podcast if you
want to do it to go order or curbside
delivery or to call the restaurant
directly don't call one of these
third-party sources it's a huge deal to
them it's a huge difference in the way
they make money if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click
the notification bell